you guys said you were governor in Iraq
and then you came back and joined
politics why did you do that
based on your experience I think I
realized that although it's incredibly
exciting to be working in other people's
country in the end if you really want to
make a change you have to return to your
own country particularly flag me you're
interested in political change because
the kind of political change which a
foreigner can bring in somebody else's
country is it's very very limited I'm
not sure I expect this I think I think
changing things through politics is very
difficult but but I do feel deeply that
the best question to impose people of of
our generation is not exactly what do
you do to countries like Afghanistan or
what you do to countries like Iraq in
other words how do you turn them into us
the more difficult question is what do
we do with our in countries where do
they go I think I'm disappointed by the
international community in general and
yes my own personal time abroad I mean
certainly when I was in Iraq it was a
disaster but I think it's a disaster too
more structural level minutes it's not
only the individual it's not only the
mistakes that I made trying to deal with
a civil war or trying to stop people
firing rockets into my building it's the
complete idea that foreigners can come
in from another country with a very
limited understanding of the language
and the culture and attempt to apply a
very very vague plan
on somebody else's society so I think
this is not just disappointing I think
it's scandalous
it's objectionable think the first thing
is the international community Holland
Britain the United States needs to
acknowledge its limits it needs to
acknowledge how little it knows how
little it can do how little legitimacy
it has we need to be honest about
ourselves we need to be honest that we
don't speak these peoples languages very
well that we are isolated in compounds
that we don't spend nights in people's
houses that we don't have long-term
commitment to these countries that we're
impatient on the one hand and on the
other hand we need to try to acknowledge
that the local society has much more
energy much more power than we ever
acknowledge that we talk about these
countries to so their failed States so
they're blank
whereas in fact there's incredible
amount of local energy institutions
practices local politicians Afghan
politicians can do much more than we
acknowledge we can do much less parcel
mission is to try to do my part to
convince people of the dignity and the
glory of politics to pull people back
into the political sphere at the moment
we live in a society which is either
obsessed with trying to change the world
that are completely crazy and possible
at one you know talking about ending
global poverty or any global conflict or
we live in a world where everybody just
gives up when they retreat into their
home and they say well what matters is
my family and I'll just get on with my
life
the complete middle ground which is the
ground of elected politics of the
citizen
has lost all its dignity and in order to
recreate it it's not just a question of
getting politicians for this bit it's a
question getting citizens to take this
seriously again to believe that there is
moral value in the Civic sphere we
should have much more belief in the idea
of politics we should encourage the
brightest of our generation not to be
management consultants but to stand for
election of local councils we should try
to ensure that we create societies where
people understand that we are political
animals that the political decisions are
the most important most virtuous parts
of our lives and that if we don't engage
with those things we create a world of
unreality that the politics is the most
real part potentially of our lives